just to look at like the day in the life
of Ben Shapiro you speak a lot
very eloquently about difficult topics
um what goes into the research the
mental part and you always look pretty
like energetic and like you're not
exhausted by the burden the heaviness of
the topics you're covering day after day
after day after day so what what goes
through the preparation uh mentally diet
wise anything like that like when do you
when do you wake up okay so I wake up
when my kids wake me up uh usually
that's my baby daughter who's two and a
half she usually here on the monitor
usually about 6 15 6 20 am and so I get
up my wife sleeps in a little bit I I go
get the baby and then my son gets up and
then my oldest daughter gets high five
eight six and two uh the the boys the
the middle child is that both the source
of stress and happiness oh my God the
height of both right I mean it's it's
the source of the greatest happiness so
the way that I characterize it is this
when it comes to sort of kids in life so
when you're single your boundaries of
happiness and unhappiness you can be a
zero in terms of happiness you can be
like a ten in terms of Happiness then
you get it goes up to like a 20 and a
negative 20 because they're happiest
stuff is with your wife and then the
most unhappy stuff is when something
happens to your spouse it's the worst
thing in the entire world then you have
kids and all limits are removed so the
best things that have have ever happened
to me are things where I'm watching my
kids and they're playing together and
they're being wonderful and sweet and
cute and I love them so much and the
worst thing is when my son is screaming
at me for no reason because he's being
insane and uh and I have to deal with
that right I mean like or or something
bad happens to my daughter at school or
something like that that stuff is really
bad so yes the source of my greatest
happiness the source of my greatest
stress so they get me up at about 6 15
in the morning I feed them breakfast I'm
kind of scrolling the news while I'm
making the mags uh and uh and you know
just updating myself on anything that
may have happened overnight I go into
the office put on the makeup and the
Wardrobe or whatever and then I sit down
and do the show a lot of the prep is
actually done the night before because
the new cycle doesn't change all that
much between
kind of late at night and in the
mornings I can supplement in the morning
so I I do the show so a lot of the
preparation like thinking through what
are the big issues in the world is done
the night before yeah I mean and that's
reading you know pretty much all the
Legacy Media so I rip on Legacy Media a
lot but that's because they a lot of
what they do is really good it's really
bad I I cover a lot of Legacy Media so
it's probably covering you know Wall
Street Journal New York Times Washington
Post Boston Globe daily mail
um and then I'll look over at some of
the alternative media I'll look at my
own website daily wire I'll look at
Breitbart I'll look at the blaze I'll
look at uh I'll look at maybe the
interest apps I'll look at you know a
bunch of different sources and then I
will look at different clips online so
media it comes in handy here grabian
comes in handy here
that sort of stuff because my show
relies very heavily on being able to
play people so you can hear them in
their own words uh and uh and so that
that's sort of the media diet so I sit
down I I do the show and then once I'm
done with the show I usually have
between now it's like 11 15 in the
morning maybe because sometimes I'll
pre-record the show so I'll 11 15 in the
morning I'll go home and if my wife's
available I'll grab lunch with her if
not then I will go and work out I try to
work out like
five times a week with a trainer
something like that and uh and then I
will just regular gym stuff just uh go
to the gym yeah weights and and
Plyometrics and
some CrossFit kind of stuff and yeah I
mean uh but beneath this beneath this
mild steel as a hulking Monster uh and
uh and so uh I'll I'll do that then I'll
um
I will do reading and writing uh so I'll
I'm usually working on a book at any
given time uh or if you shut off the the
rest of the world yes so I put some
music in my ears usually Brahms Orbach
uh sometimes Beethoven or Mozart it's
those four those are on rotation the rap
no rap no rap despite my extraordinary
rendition of whap yeah I'm not in fact
around you still do you still hate rap
um the song it's uh I will say I do not
think that it is the peak of Western
civilized art okay I I don't think that
100 years from now people will be gluing
their faces to a whap and protest at the
environment but uh Brahms and the rest
will be still around yes I would assume
if people still have a functioning
prefrontal cortex in any sort of wrong
words from Ben Shapiro all right so you
got some classical music in your ears
and you're focusing uh are you at the
computer when you're writing yeah I'm
I'm at the computer
um usually we have a kind of a room that
has some sun coming in so it's nice in
there or I'll go up to a library that we
just completed for me uh so I'll go up
there and I'll and I'll write physical
book uh yeah I love physical books and
because I because I keep Sabbath I I
don't use Kindle because when I'm
reading a book and I hit Sabbath I have
to turn off the Kindle so that means
that I have tons and tons and tons of
physical books when you move from Los
Angeles to Florida I had about 7 000
volumes I had to discard probably 4 000
of them
um and then I've built that back up now
so I'm probably gonna have to go through
another round where I put them somewhere
else I tend to tab books rather than
highlighting them because I can't
highlight on Sabbath so I have like the
the little stickers and I put them in
the book so a typical book from me you
can see it on the book club will be like
filled with tabs on the side things that
I want to take not actually uh I got a
person who I I um pay to go through and
write down in files the quotes that I've
that I like from the book so I have
those handy
um so which is a good way for me to
remember what it is that I've that I've
read
because I I read probably
somewhere between three and five books a
week uh and then the uh in a good week
five uh and then I you know write I read
and then I go pick up my kids from
school at 3 30. so according to my kids
I have no job I there I'm there in the
mornings until they leave for school I
pick them up from school I hang out with
them until they go to bed which is
usually 7 30 or so so I'm helping them
with their homework and I'm playing with
them and I'm taking them on rides in in
the brand new Tesla which my son is
obsessed with uh and uh and then I put
them to bed and then I sit back down I
prep for the next day go through all
those media sources I was talking about
compile kind of a schedule for what I
want the show to look like and and run a
show it's very detail-oriented nobody
writes anything for me I write all my
own stuff
um so every word that comes out of my
mouth is my fault and uh and then you
know hopefully I have a couple hours to
or an hour to hang out with my wife uh
before before we go to the words you
write do you edit a lot or does it just
come out you're thinking like what are
the key ideas I want to express uh no I
don't tend to edit a lot so I I thank
God I'm able to write extraordinarily so
I write very very fast in fact in a
previous life I was you also speak fast
so similarly yeah exactly and I speak in
paragraphs so it's it's exactly the same
thing uh in a previous life I was a
ghost writer so I used to be sort of
known as a turnaround specialist in the
publishing industry and be somebody who
came to the publisher and says I have
three weeks and to get this book done I
don't have a word done and they would
call me up and be like this person needs
a book written and so in three weeks I'd
knock out sixty thousand words or so is
there something you can say to the
process that you follow to think like
how you think about ideas like you stuff
is going on in the world
and trying to understand what is
happening what are the explanations what
are the forces behind this do you have a
process or or just uh you uh wait for
the Muse to give you the interpretation
I mean I think that it I don't think
it's a formal process but because I read
so there's two ways to do it one is
sometimes
you know that sometimes The Daily Grind
of the news is going to refer back to
core principles that are broader and
deeper
so I thank God because I've read so much
on so many different things of a lot of
different point of views
um then if if something breaks and a
piece of news breaks I can immediately
sort of channel that into in the mental
Rolodex these three big ideas that I
think are are really important and then
I can talk at length about what those
ideas are and I can explicate those uh
and and so you know for example when we
were talking about must taking over
Twitter before and I immediately go to
the history of media right that's that's
me tying it into a broader theme yeah uh
on you know and I do that I would say
fairly frequently we're talking about
um
say subsidization of industry and I can
immediately tie that into okay what's
the history of subsidization in the
United States going all the way back to
Woodrow Wilson and Ford through FDR's
industrial policy and how does that tie
into sort of broader Economic Policy
internationally so it allows me to tie
into bigger themes because what I tend
to read is mostly not news what I tend
to read is mostly books
I'd say most of my media diet is
actually not the stuff like that's
that's the icing on the cake but the
actual cake is the hundreds of pages in
history econ
geography that that I'm that I'm social
science that I'm reading every week and
so that that sort of stuff allows me to
to think more deeply about these things
that's one way of doing the other way of
doing it is Russia breaks in the news I
don't know anything about Russia I
immediately go and I purchase five books
about Russia and I read all of them and
so one of the unfortunate things about
our uh our the fortunate thing for me
and the unfortunate thing about the
world is that if the unfortunate thing
about the world is you read two books on
a subject you are now considered by the
media and expert on this subject uh so
that's you know sad and shallow but that
is the way that it is the good news for
me is that my job isn't to be a full
expert on any of these subjects and I
don't claim to be right I'm not a Russia
expert I know enough on Russia to be
able to understand when people talk
about Russia what the system looks like
how it works and all of that and then to
explicate that for the common man which
a lot of people who are infused with the
expertise can't really do if you're so
deep in the weeds that you're like a
full-on academic expert on a thing
sometimes it's hard to translate that
over to a mass audience which is really
my job well I think it can actually it's
funny with the two books you can
actually
get a pretty deep understanding if you
read and also think deeply about it it
allows you to approach a thing from
first principles a lot a lot of times if
you're a quote-unquote expert you get um
you get carried away by the momentum of
what the the field has been thinking
about versus like stepping back all
right what is really going on the The
Challenge is to pick the right two books
right so that usually what I'll try to
find is somebody who knows the topic
pretty well and have them recommend or a
couple people and have them recommend
books so a couple years ago I knew
nothing about Bitcoin I was at a
conference and uh a couple of people who
you've had on your show actually uh were
there and I asked them give me your top
three books on bitcoin and so then I
went and I read like nine books on
bitcoin and so if you're nine books on
bitcoin you at least know enough to get
by yeah uh and so that so I can actually
explain what Bitcoin is and why it works
or why it doesn't work in some cases and
and what's happening in the markets that
way so that that's you know very very
helpful well the Putin is an example
that's a difficult one to find the right
books on
I think the new Czar is the one I read
where was the most objective the one I
read I think about Putin was it was one
called strong man
it was very highly critical of of Putin
but it gave like a good background on
him yeah so I'm very skeptical sort of
things that are very uh they're critical
of Putin uh because it feels like
there's activism injected into the
history like the way Verizon follow the
Third Reich is written about Hitler I
like because there's almost not a
criticism of Hitler it's a description
of Hitler which is very
um it's easier to do about a historical
figure which with William Shire with the
rise of fall of the Third Reich it's
impressive because you lived through it
but it's very tough to find objective
descriptions about the history of the
man and a country of Putin of zelenski
of any difficult Trump was the same and
you I feel like that's the hero villain
archetype right and it's like either
somebody's completely a hero or
completely a villain and the truth is
pretty much no one is completely a hero
or completely a villain people in fact
I'm not sure that I love descriptions of
people as heroes or villains generally I
think that people tend to do heroic
things or do villainous things in the
same way that I'm not sure I love
descriptions of people as a genius my
dad used to say this when I was growing
up he used to say they didn't believe
that there were Geniuses he said he
believed that there were people with a
genius for something because people you
know yes they're people who are very
high IQ and we call them Geniuses but
does that mean that they're good at
EQ stuff not necessarily but there are
people who are geniuses at EQ stuff in
other words it would be more specific to
say that somebody's a genius at
engineering than to say just broad
spectrum they're a genius and that does
avoid the problem of thinking that
they're good at something that they're
not good at right it's a little more
specific